A lot can happen in a three-hour-long movie,
and plenty did in Avengers: Endgame.
Heartfelt emotion, genuinely hilarious dialogue,
and a life-or-death mission that Earth's Mightiest
Heroes embarked on - Avengers: Endgame had
it all and executed everything magnificently.
And it kept intensity high until the very
end, when it gave a fan-favorite character
a soul-stirring send-off and teased the introduction
of a new hero to take his place.
Let's break down exactly what happened.
Major spoilers ahead!
Thanos barely had time to snap his fingers
in Avengers: Infinity War before fans began
wondering what would happen in Avengers: Endgame,
specifically which dusted characters would
return from the dead and which surviving heroes
would meet their end for good.
But the common name on everyone's list of
heroes who would likely die in Avengers: Endgame
was no doubt Captain America.
Speculation heated up even further when Captain
America actor Chris Evans reiterated that
he would be retiring from the role of Steve
Rogers after Endgame.
It pains us to say it, but Captain America
did make his departure during Avengers: Endgame.
Rather than get crushed by Thanos or sacrifice
himself to protect his fellow Avengers, Steve
Rogers lives through to the end, then chooses
to go back in time by himself and return the
Infinity Stones to the places in time the
heroes took them from.
Professor Hulk explains that even though only
five seconds will pass in their time, Steve
can spend as long as he wants in the past.
And that's exactly what he does - Rogers returns
as an elderly man, clearly at the very end
of his life.
After returning the six Infinity Stones to
their rightful places, Cap chose to remain
in the past, reunite with his one true love
Peggy Carter, and grow old with her.
Steve tells all this to Sam, and then does
something big: he tells him to try on the
Captain America shield and see how it fits.
Though Falcon admits that it feels foreign,
like it will always belong to someone else,
Steve makes it clear that he wants Sam to
be the new Captain America.
So, what does this mean for the future of
the Marvel Cinematic Universe?
It seems all but guaranteed that Sam Wilson
will no longer be known as Falcon, and will
instead protect the world as the new Captain
America.
Considering such a switch-up has roots in
the Marvel comics, there is more than enough
information at hand for Marvel bigwigs to
feature Sam as Captain America in upcoming
movies.
It also helps that Sam Wilson actor Anthony
Mackie is still under contract with Marvel.
Granted, he's fulfilled the standard deal
for six movies, but the actor did previously
say that he penned a deal for, as he puts
it, "like 50" films.
As he told Vulture,
"I signed up for as many movies as I could.
I was willing to go as far as they would let
me, in whatever capacity they wanted to retain
me."
Steve passing his shield onto Sam at the end
of Avengers: Endgame might also have an effect
on the Disney+ limited series Falcon and Winter
Soldier, starring Sebastian Stan and Anthony
Mackie.
Walt Disney Studios and Marvel Studios did
previously announce the show's title and logo,
which are unlikely to change, but after what
took place in Endgame, it stands to reason
that the title characters could end up working
together as a Captain America duo.
That'd be a great team.
"Can you move your seat up?”
“No."
They were both present when old man Steve
explained his decision, and have both operated
as Captain America in the comics.
So perhaps Bucky and Sam will want to unite
and honor the legacy of the Steve they knew
as the Star-Spangled Avenger.
Then again, maybe Sam won't take up the Captain
America suit and shield and will be content
continuing to save lives as Falcon.
Anything can happen in the Marvel Cinematic
Universe, as both Infinity War and Endgame
so clearly taught us, so for now it seems
all theories about a new Captain America post-Endgame
are fair play.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about Avengers:
Endgame are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.